[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Geoffroy Didier bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec vous et secrétaire général
délégué des républicains on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice vaisser Redon du
groupe Ebra les journaux de l'Est de la
France bonjour Fabrice bonjour on va
commencer en parlant de l'Arménie
Geoffrey Didier on le rappelle vous êtes
député européen 80% de la population
duo-caraba a quitté le territoire
réfugié
Colonna la ministre des Affaires
étrangères a annoncé hier soir qu'elles
se rendrait sur place demain est-ce que
la France est à la hauteur
la France est à la hauteur de l'aide
humanitaire l'Union européenne n'est pas
à la hauteur en termes politiques parce
que Madame Van derlienne a signé un
accord gazier avec l'Azerbaïdjan qui
importe aujourd'hui 12 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz et l'Union
européenne a considéré l'Azerbaïdjan
comme je cite Madame Van derrienne un
partenaire fiable et ça ce n'est pas
acceptable ce n'est pas acceptable parce
que l'Azerbaïdjan est une dictature que
l'Arménie est une démocratie qu'il y a
aujourd'hui comme le dit Bruno
Retailleau un nettoyage ethnique au
Caraba c'est à dire que la
quasi-totalité voir la totalité des
Arméniens vont devoir quitter la région
qu'ils habitent depuis des siècles et
rejoindre tel des réfugiés l'Arménie et
l'Union européenne ferme les yeux et
pendant ce temps elle fait affaire avec
l'Azerbaïdjan ça ce n'est pas normal à
d'autres choix oui elle a d'autres choix
parce qu'il y a effectivement d'autres
pays qui fournissent du gaz je pense à
la Norvège je pense à l'Algérie nous
devons surtout
organiser notre indépendance énergétique
plutôt que d’être piégée bien sûr il
faut rompre oui oui parce que sur les
400 milliards de mètres cubes de gaz
nous avons besoin nous pouvons
parfaitement faire autrement et
supprimer les 12 milliards de mètres
cubes par an à portée par laserbaïdjan
pour envoyer un signal un signal
politique un signal culturel pour
s'affirmer politiquement et donc
effectivement lorsque Madame van dereyen
dit que l'Arménie est un partenaire
fiable comment voulez-vous après que
l'on critique laserbaïdjan comment
voulez-vous qu'on critique ensuite
l'Arménie et qu'on soit libre de dire ce
que l'on veut vis-à-vis de de ce qui est
en train de se passer c'est-à-dire se
nettoyage ethnique aux portes de
l'Europe pourquoi dans le recadre à 4
heures d'avion Paris c'est techniquement
possible ces matériellement possible
pourquoi on ne le rend pas selon vous ce
contrat parce que je crois qu'il n'y a
pas de volonté politique de la part de
l'Union européenne c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi j'ai décidé de me rendre
dans les prochains jours en Arménie pour
me désolidariser de cette politique de
l'Union européenne parce que l'Union
européenne n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait
en matière énergétique parce que nous
avons été dépendantes totalement des
Allemands parce que aujourd'hui il y a
des centrales à charbon qui sont en
Allemagne parce que en France Emmanuel
Macron malheureusement a fait le choix
de quitter le nucléaire en renonçant au
projet Astrid en fermant Fessenheim
avant de se rendre compte qu'en réalité
il n'y avait pas d'autres choix que de
conserver et que de et que de d'investir
dans le nucléaire donc vous voyez si
cette succession de renoncement
d'abandon successifs qui font
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes piézés points
liés à l'Azerbaïdjan dont chacun
s'accorde à dire que c'est une dictature
et dont chacun s'accorde à dire qu'il
est en train de tempérer un nettoyage
est-ce que la France peut et doit se
désolidarité se désolidariser pardon de
la position de l'Union européenne à ce
moment-là je le crois vraiment je crois
que si Madame Colonna sera en Arménie
demain et c'est une bonne chose qu'elle
s'y rendent elle doit certes adresser un
message humanitaire mais aussi un
message politique on ne peut pas se
contenter de dire qu'il faut sauver les
Arméniens et qu'il faut faut tout faire
pour éviter ce qui est en train de se
passer dans l'eau Caraba sans en tirer
des enseignements politiques lorsqu'on
est ministre des affaires européennes et
des affaires et des questions
internationales lorsqu'on est président
de la Commission européenne on prend ses
responsabilités devant les citoyens on
va passer au budget Fabrice avec une
première question oui Emmanuel Macron va
annoncer aujourd'hui 200 endormis
supplémentaires en France le recrutement
de 2000 policiers c'est un
investissement important pour vous c'est
utile dans le budget français si ça
correspond à une réalité effectivement
Emmanuel Macron à chaque fois nous parle
de beaucoup de choses il nous prometz et
merveilles mais la beauté c'est 200
euros
vous savez voter des lois et je le dis
dans cet enceinte
on vote des lois et c'est heureux mais
le problème n'est plus le vote des lois
le problème c'est l'application des lois
le véritable problème c'est est-ce que
les lois ce qui est décidé ce qui est
annoncé dans les journaux de 20 heures
effectivement mise en oeuvre et il y a
toujours d'ici 2027 c'est 200 brigades
écoutez je ne demande qu'à espérer et
avoir et à constater ce que je constate
surtout c'est que dans le projet de
budget il y a la fin des dépenses
exceptionnelles mais qu'il n'y a pas en
réalité de d'économie structurelle et
puis ce que je voudrais aussi c'est que
si on fait des économies structurelles
et là il faut être courageux il y a
quand même beaucoup de gaspillage
beaucoup de fraudes contre lesquels il
faut lutter beaucoup de dépenses et de
structures inutiles que tout cela ne
sert pas à rien parce qu'il faut rendre
l'argent en français parce qu'il faut
les soulager fiscalement il y a beaucoup
de signaux fiscaux adressés aux Français
en faisant des économies structurelles
et l'État ne s'est pas vraiment décidé à
le faire je vais pas vous rappeler les
chiffres de la dette je ne vais pas vous
rappeler les chiffres du déficit public
parce qu'ils sont en fait insultants
pour la politique d'emmanuels qui a été
présenté cette semaine il y a quand même
16 milliards d'économies donc 15
milliards de fin de dépenses
exceptionnelles où sont les dépenses en
moins structurelles où sont les
économies qui s'attaquent par exemple
aux structures inutiles permettez-moi de
vous donner un exemple concret il existe
en France je cite le Conseil national de
l'alimentation
l'Institut national de la consommation
l'observatoire de l'alimentation
l'Observatoire de la formation des prix
et des marges des produits alimentaires
et enfin pour couronner le tout le
Conseil national de la consommation vous
croyez que c'est ça coûte cher mais le
problème c'est que aucune idée le
problème le problème
le diable est dans les détails il n'y en
a pas que 5 il y en a 450 les
observatoires des commissariats des
instituts des conseils nationaux il y en
a 450 donc déjà supprimons une grande
partie des 450 supprimons les doublons
ayant ce courage ayant aussi le courage
par exemple lorsqu'on l'a proposé
erikiotti de diminuer le temps et le
montant de l'indemnisation chômage parce
que il faut tout faire pour encourager
l'activité et ne jamais installer ne
jamais installer nos concitoyens dans un
sentiment selon lequel travailler ou ne
pas travailler reviennent eux-mêmes ça a
pas été suffisamment fait par le
gouvernement non ça n'a pas été
suffisamment fait c'est pour ça qu'on
demande une étape de plus c'est-à-dire
et c'est davantage lutter contre les
fraudes non non c'est pas vrai je ne
crois pas il y a 2 millions de Français
au RSA aujourd'hui il y en a beaucoup
qui du fait de l'inflation considère
qu'en fait il est désormais plus
intéressant de travailler que de ne pas
travailler et qui sont donc encouragés
au travail et faisons tout pour
démontrer par exemple pour durcir les
règles oui non non c'est pas qu'on le
sauver c'est que c'est nous qui l'avons
proposé par delémoire et le gouvernement
a suivi et effectivement je suis fier
que les républicains aient porté
contrairement d'ailleurs aurassemblement
national qui n'a pas voté cet amendement
que il est désormais une contrepartie en
face du versement du RSA 15 heures d'A
par semaine contre le versement du RSA
vous voyez c'est juste c'est juste c'est
dire que nous avons tout nous devons
tout faire pour que le travail
récompense toujours mieux que
l'assistanat ou que l'inactivité parce
que tous ceux qui sont inactifs ne sont
pas des assistés bien évidemment et
encourager chacun au travail il y a du
boulot il faut qu'on aide chacun à s'y
mettre évidemment il y a ceux qui ne
peuvent pas travailler il y a ceux qui
n'ont pas eu de chance dans la vie il y
a ceux qui sont sur le bas-côté et cela
il faut les aider mais pour mieux les
aider il faut aussi supprimer
ces structures inutiles et supprimer
toutes les dépenses superfétatoires
alors vous présenter un contre budget
quelles seront les grandes lignes les
grandes lignes c'est exactement ce que
je viens de vous dire c'est-à-dire une
baisse
structurelle de la dépense publique pour
se redonner les moyens de libérer les
Français en baissant les prélèvements
obligatoires ce que je veux vous dire
par là
aussi proposera et rendra public un
contre budget je lui laisse le soin de
le faire ce que je veux d'ores et déjà
vous dire c'est la philosophie c'est à
dire que nous ne sommes pas des adeptes
vous allez vous
aider on s'attaque pas au fonctionnaires
il y a pas de bêtes
j'ai des fonctionnaires dans ma famille
chacun est marqué par un professeur dans
son éducation
j'ai un immense respect pour les 5
millions et demi de fonctionnaires qui
servent dans leur immense majorité
l'état
reprocher au gouvernement c'est baisser
le nombre de fonctionnaires que la
droite s'attaque au fonctionnaires ce
n'est pas vrai en revanche qu'il y a des
fonctionnaire dans votre contre budget
je ne peux pas encore vous le garantir
ce que je veux vous dire et moi ce qui
est important ce matin c'est la
philosophie qui nous anime c'est à dire
que premièrement nous nous attaquons pas
à la fonction publique dans son essence
et surtout pas aux hommes et femmes qui
servent l'État avec passion et dont
l'émission devrait être d'ailleurs
valoriser premièrement deuxièmement si
on baisse la dépense publique c'est pour
rendre l'argent aux Français c'est à
dire que moi je ne je n'aspire pas à la
médaille field ou au prix Nobel de la
rigueur budgétaire ce que je veux en
revanche c'est que l'argent qui éc
minimiser ce que je vous disais là les
conseils nationaux les instituts les
observatoires tout ça on les supprime
pour rendre l'argent aux Français et là
nous avons des pistes là nous avons des
pistes Eric ciottier par exemple
proposer que sur les deux euros par
litre de carburant il y ait 15 centimes
qui soit rendu au français parce que
vous savez quand même ou peut-être ne
savez-vous ou pas que sur les deux euros
par litre l'État en récupère plus de la
moitié la TICPE et la TVA sur la TICPE
c'est-à-dire la taxe sur la taxe la taxe
au carré ça c'est un dessin et l'État
doit rendre l'argent et puis à titre
personnel moi je fais des propositions
je souhaite par exemple que les droits
de succession soient abolis en France
c'est le cas dans beaucoup de pays
d'Europe c'est le cas dans beaucoup de
pays dans le monde je considère que si
nous voulons encourager la transmission
et qui si nous voulons permettre à nos
concitoyens de de travailler de faire
des sacrifices pour créer un capital et
pouvoir le transmettre à leurs enfants
ou leurs petits-enfants c'est sain et
taxer le capital des Français imposer la
peine de mort au capital des Français
c'est mal sain donc supprimons-le c'est
1,5% seulement des recettes fiscales de
l'État du coup
mais encore une fois des dépenses
structurelles en moins et une grande
partie ses dépenses structurelles en moi
mais vous savez comment ça fonctionne si
on redistribue et qu'on baisse les
prélèvements obligatoires les Français
vont consommer et si les Français
consomment on relance l'économie donc en
fait il faut opérer un cercle vertueux
plutôt encore une fois que d'être les
adeptes de la rigueur budgétaire en tout
cas c'est pas exactement ce que je
souhaite vous faites un nouveau Planet
la menace d'une motion de censure sur le
texte immigration tout le groupe de
l'Assemblée nationale vous suit sur le
sujet une grande partie je crois
pourquoi parce que c'est
bien pour ça que même si évidemment je
suis prudent je crois que une immense
majorité des députés LR seront d'accord
mais pourquoi parce que c'est un texte
fondamental moi je n'utilise pas les
républicains n'utilisent pas l'émotion
de censure à tort et à travers la motion
de censure c'est une arme létale et
c'est une arme fatale donc on ne peut
pas l'utiliser tous les jours ou même
chaque sous prétexte qu'on a désaccord
avec le gouvernement et Dieu sait qu'ils
sont nombreux en revanche sur
l'immigration c'est un point fondamental
sur l'article 3 du projet Loi de
l'immigration qui permet de régulariser
des clandestins qui travaillent c'est
fondamental pourquoi parce que d'abord
si tu n'es pas d'accord mais c'est le
principe et c'est une erreur politique à
ce titre là d'accorder une prime à la
fraude en plus c'est une erreur
empirique parce que tout ça va créer des
appels d'air et enfin c'est une erreur
économique parce que comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure sur les 2 millions
de Français qui touchent le RSA beaucoup
du fait de l'inflation sont aujourd'hui
encouragés à travailler considérant
qu'en fait ils ont besoin de travailler
pour gagner plus d'argent donc cette
triple erreur fatale pour le
gouvernement nous permet de considérer
que c'est l'heure des choix pour
Emmanuel Macron donc si il ne peut plus
permettre il ne peut plus en tout cas
c'est mon souhait il ne peut plus
aujourd'hui être un adepte du non-soi
faire semblant de maîtriser les flux
migratoires et accorder une prime à la
fraude mais tout simplement ne serait-ce
que par respect pour les immigrés qui
ont eu respect nos valeurs et respecter
nos règles si vous dites aux Français
comme aux étrangers que vous respectiez
les lois que vous les respectiez pas ça
revient au même comment voulez-vous que
tous ceux qui nous regardent soient
encouragés à respecter les lois oui mais
Emmanuel Macron il dit c'est de
l'hypocrisie parce que sur le terrain
même les députés de droite nous disent
qu'ils ont besoin de ces personnes là
c'est de la manipoliticienne pour
essayer de de
fosser le débat vous voyez j'estime pas
ça sans dire que nous nous avançons avec
des principes mais bien sûr qu'il peut y
avoir au cas par cas en fonction de
situation
une régularisation quelques
régularisations parce que il y a des
histoires de famille parce que il y a
les histoires de très longue date et
puis surtout je vous le rappelle il y a
quand même l'asile politique qui fait
l'honneur à la France et qui permet à
des personnes qui viennent de pays en
danger enfin depuis où ils sont en
danger en danger de de mort d'être
accueilli dignement sur notre territoire
au nom de l'asile politique mais si on
veut pouvoir accueillir dignement on ne
peut pas accueillir mais juste est-ce
que vous êtes en position de force parce
que même ici au Sénat vos alliés sont
tristes ne vous suivent pas sur ce sujet
eux ils sont pour cet article 3 mais
c'est pas pour ça qu'on va renoncer à
nos convictions tout est une bataille
politique la politique c'est convaincre
la politique c'est convaincre s'il
existe des principes fondamentaux et que
non mais l'objectif est d'être en
majorité n'est pas d'être en minorité et
surtout d'envoyer un signal un signal
très fort au gouvernement en lui
imposant désormais le faire des choix et
d'arrêter de tirer à eux et à dire comme
il le font depuis tant d'années est-ce
que vous êtes en position de l'envoyer
ce signalez nous ferons tout seul nous
ferons tout pour ferme sur nos positions
très au clair sur ce que nous pensons
avec un projet loi constitutionnel clé
en main que nous attendons de voir
repris par le gouvernement avec une idée
très simple c'est que oui ou non
Emmanuel Macron acceptera-t-il de
réformer la Constitution pour nous
redonner le pouvoir en matière
migratoire oui ou non acceptera-t-il
enfin que nous faisions fille de la
jurisprudence extensive des courses
européennes qui ne nous permettent plus
aujourd'hui de maîtriser nos frontières
et de reconduire un immigré clandestins
c'est quand même incroyable moi
justement je crois
l'Europe mais l'Europe manifestement
faut la remettre à l'endroit faut pas la
remettre par terre comme le propose le
rassemblement national et Marion
Maréchal-Le Pen la remettre à l'endroit
et c'est exactement le défi des
élections européennes qui nous attendent
c'est exprimé il y a quelques quelques
heures disons il fallait écouter il
fallait avoir une oreillette antique au
pape François et ne pas laisser les gens
se noyer en parlant de ces migrants
philosophiquement vous en pensez quoi il
a raison le pape François il a raison
parce que je n'ai pas compris les
critiques qui ont été émises sur les
déclarations du pape François si le pape
François nous disait que il ne fallait
pas accueillir tout le monde vous serez
plus pape je crois que il a raison mais
vous le suivez pas non mais attendez il
a raison en tant que Pape
la politique une humaine la politique
indignes c'est celle qui prétend pouvoir
accueillir tout le monde et qui fait que
aujourd'hui nous avons ces immigrés qui
arrivent en France ces étrangers et qui
se retrouvent vivant dans des conditions
totalement insalubre Porte de la
Chapelle donc aujourd'hui nous ne sommes
pas en mesure d'accueillir dignement
tous ceux qui souhaitent et puis je vous
rappelle un défi démographique majeur
1,3 milliards aujourd'hui d'habitants en
Afrique demain en 2050 c'est-à-dire dans
une seule génération c'est le double
dont la moitié des africains avec moins
avec un âge de moins de 20 ans donc en
fait nous savons pertinemment ce qui
nous attend si aujourd'hui ne n'en
voyons pas un signal de clarté et de
respect des lois et ça ne veut pas dire
être pour l'immigration zéro absolument
pas nous nous sommes pour une
immigration choisie maîtrisée
précisément parce que
oui mais il ne le fait pas
mais moi je pense que Gérald darmann est
un homme de droite et le problème c'est
qu'il est aujourd'hui prisonnier du
non-soi et de qui est d'ailleurs
théorisé par Emmanuel Macron donc en
fait qui adopte nos positions mais
surtout qu'il les votent ou qu'il les
mette véritablement sur la table mais en
donnant une prime à la fraude au clan
des seins avoué quand même qu'il n'est
pas vraiment un homme de droite en tout
cas dans son comportement question sur
Laurent Wauquiez Fabrice oui vous étiez
à Valence ce week-end pour la fête des
jeunes de votre mouvement politique
Laurent Wauquiez s'est dit prêt
pour 2027 c'est de la pas dire
rigoureusement comme ça est-ce qu'il est
à la hauteur de vos attentes Laurent ok
alors à titre personnel je préfère à ce
stade me concentrer sur les idées
puisque j'ai été chargée par le
président des républicains Richie des
états généraux de la droite qui est une
vaste réflexion qui permet de donner de
la cohérence et de réaffirmer la
consistance mais je vais pas
je préfère toujours les idées je préfère
toujours les idées aux hommes oui mais
il est le bon candidat pour porter nous
le verrons en tout cas ce que je peux
vous dire d'ores et déjà non non ce que
je peux vous dire d'ores et déjà c'est
que manifestement ici prépare et que sa
méthode est la bonne parce que celle qui
consiste à s'éloigner des Microtus des
tweets du jour ou des phrases du moment
et à mon avis saine et pour celui qui
veut transformer son parcours en destin
je crois que le recul qu'il prend la
hauteur et la distance par rapport au
brouhaha politique et est nécessaire
donc je pense que sa méthode est là-bas
non je ne comprends pas Philippe je ne
le crois pas vous savez
je vois qu'Edouard Philippe pour lequel
j'ai du respect parce que parce qu'il y
a des choses qu'il a faites qui
évidemment aller dans le bon sens et que
c'est un homme venu de la droite mais je
vois que
en tout cas il agit de concert avec des
hommes de gauche et surtout il a été
manifestement lui aussi en étant le
premier ministre d'Emmanuel Macron un
adepte du non-soi pendant plusieurs
années mais ce que je vous dire c'est
que on voit bien je sais qu'il y a des
élus ici au Sénat qui ont rejoint
Édouard Philippe mais pardon de le dire
en tant qu'élu avec toute l'humilité que
nous devons avoir les élus ne font pas
les élections les codes de popularité ne
font pas les succès électoraux sinon ça
serait et sinon Jacques Delors Edouard
Balladur où Laurent Fabius aurait été
président de la République ce n'est pas
comme ça que ça marche en fait la
démocratie sur le peuple ça ne
fonctionne pas et tous ceux qui ont
tenté la démocratie sans le peuple se
sont retrouvés dans le cimetière des
favoris donc je crois aujourd'hui que
Laurent Wauquiez a une méthode
rigoureuse à laquelle il se tient qu'il
a manifestement et c'était le message
d'hier à Valence une détermination tant
mieux et je pense surtout que la méthode
qui consiste à prendre du recul et de
distance était pas saine
il va inaugurer le QG de son parti
est-ce qu'il sera un bon candidat mais
on va pas pas faire on va pas tous les
prendre et je vous dire est-ce que c'est
un bon candidat moi ce que je veux c'est
un homme de droite à l'Élysée mais pas
une fausse droite et pas non plus une
extrême droite parce qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'être extrémiste pour être
offensif et que je crois que les les
Français vont à un moment comprendre
pour ceux qui ont ce sont tournés vers
Emmanuel Macron et je ne les accuse de
rien on comprend qu'en fait la fosse
droite ça ne fonctionne pas et qui n'est
pas nécessaire d'être violent comme il
sa droite le premier donc une droite
républicaine forte offensive qui qui
redonne du sens à la loi au respect de
la loi et à la mise en œuvre de la loi
mais qui porte aussi un projet de
société positif parce qu'on ne gagnera
pas avec du sang et des larmes vous
évoquez vous évoquez la méthode boquée
tout à l'heure vous l'avez observé sur
ces 10 dernières années est-ce qu'il a
réellement changé oui je crois je crois
qu'il est en train de faire une une
introspection par rapport à lui-même
certes parce qu'il y a aussi essuyé les
échecs comme tout le monde en politique
et en train de réfléchir à à ce que
en France
peut accepter comme réforme c'est à dire
des réformes très ambitieuses parce que
je pense que les Français sont tout à
fait prêts à la réforme mais encore une
fois avec un projet de société c'est un
chemin positif pas uniquement de la
rigueur du son et des larmes parce que
ça ça ne fonctionne pas même si c'est
évidemment nécessaire la dépense
publique comment les départager ça nous
le verrons
nous avons soupé les primaires et
vous avez bien vu que ça n'a pas
toujours marché et bien moi ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'un candidat naturel
s'impose s'impose et ça c'est au
meilleur de l'emporter si je peux me
permettre de parler ainsi écouter nous
le verrons encore une fois on en est pas
tout à fait là déjà au front un chemin
aux Français créons une piste de
décollage pour un candidat et nous
verrons après quel est celui qui est le
mieux à même de porter ce projet de
société un dernier mot sur les
européennes vous n'avez toujours pas
désigné votre tête de liste
François-Xavier Bellamy c'est pas une
évidence
avec François-Xavier nous avons au
Parlement européen pendant 5 ans mener
les combats obtenus des résultats appris
aussi a pris beaucoup sur le
fonctionnement de l'Europe nous avons
régulé pour la première fois les réseaux
sociaux dans le monde nous avons obtenu
la taxe carbone aux frontières qui est
en application depuis hier nous avons
interdit le hijab dans les promotions et
les publicités de la Commission
européenne bref nous avons mené les
combats culturels économiques et
politiques ce n'est pas à moi de décider
ce que je peux vous dire c'est quelle
est la liste des élections européennes
doit incarner une crédibilité une
expérience une légitimité et
François-Xavier Bellamy dans les
évidemment pas dénué c'est bien aussi le
sens de mon propos et ne surtout pas
s'adonner à des castings à la mode ou à
des des
favoris du moment parce que ce serait un
risque pourquoi parce que l'Europe est
un défi trop sérieux la survie notre
famille politique
suis pas de porter la liste aux
Européennes ce serait une bonne chose
erichi n'exclut pas de porter la liste
européenne non je crois qu'Eric Ciotti
sans vouloir parler pour lui
est aujourd'hui un président des
républicains
très affirmé très combatif très
occupé très préoccupé par le sort de la
des Français et je pense aujourd'hui ah
mais vous savez en politique chacun sa
place sur le plateau chacun à sa place
vous êtes journaliste je suis politique
et c'est que ce soit français ce que je
souhaite c'est que nous nous en fait ce
que je vous dis c'est que la différence
entre Jordan Bardella Marion Maréchal-Le
Pen d'un côté et nous c'est précisément
la crédibilité d'expérience donc faisons
vie cette crédibilité et puis encore une
fois comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure mais j'insiste nous on veut
réformer Bruxelles eux ils veulent
détruire l'Europe et ce sont des
différences fondamentales parce que ceux
que je vous ai cités sont des héritiers
de famille politique qui ont toujours
combattu l'Europe nous nous croyons
l'Europe en revanche on veut la remettre
à l'endroit merci Geoffrey merci merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité merci
Fabrice à la semaine prochaine la
semaine prochaine pas de souci